ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen wie
sicher ist Vladimir Putins macht wer
könnte ihm gefährlich werden wer sind
seine Gegner wie stark ist die
Opposition und was steckt hinter den
Sabotageakten in Russland von denen auch
hier bei uns immer wieder berichtet wird
darüber sprechen wir heute Abend und
zwar mit dem russischen Geheimdienst
Experten andre soldatov er und seine
Frau arbeiten als Kreml kritische
Journalisten im Exil in London und
dorthin schalten wir auch gleich und wir
freuen uns auf Ihre und eure Fragen und
Kommentare wie immer in die Kommentare
oder wenn ihr die ZDF heute App nutzt an
die eingeblendete E-Mail-Adresse ZDF
heute - live.at zdf.de
jetzt begrüße ich direkt zu Beginn
unserer Sendung Herrn soldatov wie
gesagt zugeschaltet aus London sie waren
schon oft bei uns in der Sendung sie
kennen das sie kennen die vielen
Kommentare und Fragen unserer Userinnen
und User und wir freuen uns wenn wir
viele davon heute beantworten können
Herr Soldat auf die größte Frage die wir
zu Beginn der Sendung gestellt haben ist
wie sicher ist Putins macht was ist ihre
Antwort
vielen Dank und guten Abend danke für
die Einladung ja
Putins macht ist ziemlich sicher
momentan gibt es keine seriösen
Gruppierungen im krabbel oder
umkremen die als Konkurrenz agieren
könnten für Putin
sogar dir
Geheimdienste haben jetzt eine
spezifische Lage sie ist dadurch
gehackterisiert dass es ziemlich schwer
seine Opposition dazu finden
wir werden gleich auf mögliche Gegner
mögliche Konkurrenten eingehen aber zu
Beginn noch mal die Frage wenn sie sagen
er sitzt so fest im Sattel können Sie
noch mal erklären warum gelingt es ihm
die Oligarchen die Geheimdienste den
Machtapparat so hinter sich zu
versammeln dass es schwer wird für eine
andere Person diese Rolle zu übernehmen
zu einem schauen wir auf die letzten
sieben Jahre im Laufe dieser Zeit
versuchter Puten ziemlich aktiv Menschen
loszuwerden auch diejenigen die
vielleicht die selbe Ideologie haben
aber die auch ambitioniert wurden das
heißt seine Freunde aus dem Anfang der
2000er Jahre sind jetzt weg da gab es
ambitionierte Menschen
sie wären bereits als Konkurrenz zu
agieren unter bestimmten Umständen aber
bis zum Jahre
2015/2016 waren sie alle weg
danach gab es punktuelle repressalen so
kann man das nennen
Opfer davon wurden nicht nur
JournalistInnen
Oppositionelle aber auch kurveneure und
auch Geheimdienstler
in dieser Situation
ein Versuch zu starten eine Grube zu
organisieren die als Konkurrenz für
Putin agieren kann ist sehr schwer und
es gibt auch ein Beispiel vom
Nachbarland nämlich von Belarus da hat
man das folgende gesehen 80% der
Bevölkerung ist gegen Lukaschenko aber
Lukaschenko ist an der Macht weil er
sehr brutal vorgeht das dient als
Beispiel für mehrere Menschen in den
russischen Geheimdiensten sie haben
verstanden es ist besser auf Putin zu
setzen das sorgt für Stabilität und für
die Position an der Macht
sie haben angesprochen dass es viele
potenzielle Gegner gab die ausgeschaltet
wurden aber es gibt ja auch heute
mehrere Personen denen man
möglicherweise zutrauen könnte
Konkurrenz für Putin zu sein wer das
sein könnte darauf werfen wir einen
genaueren Blick Keilriemen stellt uns
die Kandidaten vor
der Überfall auf die Ukraine verläuft
für die russische Armee ganz anders als
geplant statt schneller Erfolge immense
Verluste mit den militärischen
Rückschlägen wird lange unterdrückte
Kritik an der Militärführung laut unter
anderem von extrem nationalistischen
Kommentatoren und Bloggern aber auch in
Putins Umfeld zum Beispiel von der
61-Jährige Unternehmer auch Putins Koch
genannt ist Gründer der Söldnergruppe
Wagner der immer wieder Verstöße gegen
die Menschenrechte vorgeworfen wird
priorch ins Truppe versucht sich auch in
der Ostukraine Erfolge zu erkämpfen
Krieger selbst kritisierte zuletzt
Verteidigungsminister sergejoggo
kritik kommt auch von dem
tschetschenischen Staatschef Ramsan
kadirov er gilt als Putins Bluthund und
soll besonders skrupellos sein der Ruf
seiner Kämpfer soll auch in der Ukraine
Angst und Schrecken verbreiten
ausgerechnet caddirev wurde im Oktober
von Putin zum Generaloberst befördert
eine ins Ausland geflohene FSB
Mitarbeiterin berichtet im Oktober dass
der Inlandsgeheimdienst in prigotten und
kardihof die größte Gefahr für Putins
macht sieht
tja wir sehen hier wenn ich in die
Kommentare Blicke unter anderem schreibt
einen User namens TLK Kurs Putin hat
viele Gegner zwei haben wir jetzt gerade
gesehen lassen Sie uns darüber reden
Herr soldatov der Spiegel schreibt das
hilft geniuszin den wir gerade gesehen
haben die furchterregendste Figur des
Jahres ist der neue politische Star und
derzeit auch der aussichtsreichste
Anwärter auf die Nachfolge Putins wie
sehen Sie das
hat an Wirkung gewonnen im Vergleich zum
vorigen Jahr das sieht man in mehreren
Bereichen in erster Linie natürlich die
Tätigkeit seiner wagnergruppe vor kurzem
wurde seine neue Zentrale in St
Petersburg eröffnet ganz ordentlich hat
er zugegeben dass das seine Gesellschaft
ist er hat ganz offen davon gesprochen
dass er sich in die amerikanischen
Wahlen 2016 eingemischt hat und da hat
er behauptete dass er das weiter tun
wird er hat tatsächlich das
Verteidigungsministerium kritisiert
insbesondere im Sommer und im September
aber überschätzen sie nicht diesen
Faktor viele Sachen im Prinzip alle
Sachen die Frisuren macht sind von
quermal erlaubt
Vladimir Putin hat tatsächlich
die
Oberbefehlshaber vom russischen
Streitkräften in der Ukraine ersetzt
jetzt ist generalbüro Wicken der
Oberbefehlshaber und seitdem hat
pregorian aufgehört mit seiner Kritik er
hat den generalisturalviken nicht
kritisiert hat das auch nicht getan
natürlich möchte ein offiziellen Posten
bekommen das ist offensichtlich
es kann sein er will stellvertretender
Vorsitzender des Sicherheitsrates werden
dann würde er diese offizielle Stelle
haben und der nötigen Ruf innerhalb der
russischen Bürokratie ob er nun als
wirklicher Konkurrenz für Puten gesehen
werden kann meiner Meinung nach ist das
einer Fehleinschätzung
hat ja keine unabhängigen
Finanzierungsquellen er ist von keinem
oleganen unterstützt er hat keine eigene
politische Partei obwohl es gab diese
Gerüchteküche dass er vielleicht eine
Partei gründen wird aber ich glaube das
wird nicht passieren
wie sehen Sie das mit kadirov
a
und seiner Methoden sehen sehr ähnlich
aus
im Vergleich mit prägursen er provoziert
die ganze Zeit und so erweitert er
seinen Tätigkeitsbereich
seine Aktionen insbesondere im Herbst
haben es klar gemacht alles was er macht
wurde vom creamel erlaubt die Kritik die
er im Social Media geäußert hatte
machte er als er sich im Gebäude des
Präsidialamtes befunden hat physisch er
hatte da treffen mit verschiedenen
Vertretern der Macht gehabt das wurde
von russischen Journalisten verifiziert
als generales Europa
befällt aber promoviert wurde gab es
keine Kritik mehr auch seitens von
meiner Meinung nach es gab Probleme
tatsächlich im September beim Rückzug
der Streitkräfte mit der öffentlichen
Meinung aber als surroviken zum
oberstbefehl habe
wurde gab es nicht so viel Kritik und
die Telegramm Kanäle wurden unter
Kontrolle gesetzt diejenigen die die
Lage kritisiert haben es gibt nur wenige
Ausnahmen zum Beispiel
ultra-nationalistische Kämpfer er war
Verteidigungsminister in der
donetzka Volksrepublik noch 2014 glaube
ich
alle anderen haben verstanden man sollte
am Kreml dienen und man soll so agieren
wieder Kreml das vorschreibt denn sonst
kann einem das passieren was
verschiedenen kremlkritikern unter
anderem passiert ist ein User namens
Serdar K schreibt über Youtube wieso
verunglücken so viele Russen und fallen
aus hotelfenstern damit spielt Serdar
auf einen Vorfall an den wir gerade
berichtet sehen einen russischer
regionalabgeordneter namens Pavel antov
ist in Indien angeblich aus dem dritten
Stock seines Hotels in den Tod gestürzt
eigentlich wollte er seinen 60 66
Geburtstag feiern kurz zuvor hat er
jedoch über WhatsApp die Raketen da drin
Angriffe auf die Ukraine als Terror
bezeichnet und das ist ihm offenbar
nicht gut bekommen ist das das was
passiert wenn man den Kreml kritisiert
offenbar
in diesem Fall spielt es eigentlich
keine große Rolle Opa ob es um ein
Unfall handelt oder ob es ihm dazu
geholfen wurde aus diesem Fenster zu
fallen wichtiger ist es wie die
russische Gesellschaft die russische
Öffentlichkeit darauf reagiert in den
letzten 10 bis 12 Jahren gab es so viele
plötzliche Tode und Journalisten von
Oligarchen
von Regierungsmitgliedern deswegen gibt
es jetzt diese Atmosphäre diese Angst
hat Atmosphäre in Moskau wir können uns
auch die Zahl von Toten von russischem
Diplomaten nach 2016 anschauen
vergleichen Sie das mit dem Verhalten
vom russischen Außenminister lavrove er
hat mehrmals gesagt dass er eigentlich
zurücktreten will nun sagt er nichts
mehr er ist ein Kreisel er wird zum
Kriegsverbrecher er kann nicht weg das
betrifft auch viele anderen
Regierungsvertreter sie wissen es nicht
genau ob es ein Mord oder ein Wort war
aber sie verstehen dass eins als ein
Signal man soll vorsichtig sein
dann so viele sterben so plötzlich
wenn sie sagen es kommt darauf an wie
die russische Bevölkerung damit umgeht
wir sind die Reaktionen darauf wird es
überhaupt berichtet in Russland
nun die Bevölkerung die der Leute
unterhalten sich nicht öffentlich das
öffentlich zu machen wir zu gefährlich
wir sehen es ja tagtäglich die
Möglichkeit der öffentlichen Diskussion
wird geringer es ist nicht möglich denn
Krieg öffentlich zu besprechen nehmen
sie mein Beispiel ich gegen mich wird es
ermittelt weil ich angeblich falschen
Formationen über den Angriff auf die
Ukraine verbreitet hätte
zehn Jahre
Freiheitsstrafe das ist das was man
droht wenn ich nach Russland zurückkehre
und natürlich man spürt diese Atmosphäre
diese Angst hat Atmosphäre und natürlich
versteht jeder heutzutage kann man
jegliche Sachen erwarten und repress
Büchern kommen wir kommen gleich noch
mal gesondert auf die Möglichkeit
Widerstand zu leisten und auf das was
passiert wenn man so wie sie gerade
sagen auch Kritik geäußert oder versucht
die Wahrheit zu sagen
Katie Penelope schreibt über Youtube
warum lässt sich die Bevölkerung das
alles gefallen die Antwort wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe darauf ist Angst lassen
Sie uns einen Blick darauf werfen wie
dieser Macht Zirkel funktioniert und wer
dazu gehört zu Putin auch das hat
Keilriemen noch mal zusammengefasst
wladimir Putin hat in den vergangenen
Jahren einen Machtzirkel mit Männern um
sich gebildet von denen einige auch über
den geplanten Überfall auf die Ukraine
gewusst haben soll viktor solothoff ist
Chef der Nationalgarde die wird
eingesetzt um Demonstrationen und
Widerstand im eigenen Land
niederzuschlagen und ist auch in der
Ukraine aktiv Putin und solothoff kennen
sich aus kgb-zeiten der General gilt als
uneingesch loyal Sergej Schoigu ist
Verteidigungsminister und gilt als enger
Freund Putins in den vergangenen Wochen
stand der vermehrt in der Kritik da der
Krieg in der Ukraine nicht so läuft wie
sich der Kreml das wünscht
genau wie Valerie girassimov als
generalstabchef der Streitkräfte
Russlands ist der 67-Jährige direkt für
die von der russischen Armee verübten
Kriegsverbrechen in der Ukraine
verantwortlich
auch die russischen Geheimdienste werden
für die eklatante Fehleinschätzung im
Ukraine Krieg verantwortlich gemacht
Alexander bortnikow leitet den
Inlandsgeheimdienst FSB seine Leute
sorgen dafür dass demokratischer
Widerstand in Russland im Keim erstickt
wird der FFB spioniert aber auch in der
Ukraine
ist Leiter des Auslandsgeheimdienstes
SWR er soll in den 1980er Jahren
zusammen mit Wladimir Putin an der KGB
eigenen Hochschule studiert haben kurz
vor Beginn des Krieges viel auf die
Putin den 68-Jährigen in einer Sitzung
des Sicherheitsrates abkannte
Chef ist Chef der Sicherheitsrates seien
Einfluss auf putin wird als besonders
groß eingeschätzt er kontrolliert den
gesamten Sicherheitsapparat und er hasst
den Westen und die westlichen Werte
Herr soldato auf diesen Zirkel der Macht
haben wir gesehen ausschließlich Männer
Frauen spielen offenbar keine Rolle wie
gesagt die Zusammensetzung kennen wir
aber wie funktioniert die Architektur
woran hängen die Loyalitäten warum
funktioniert das offenbar
ich glaube unsere Zuschauer haben das
wahrscheinlich gesehen da sind alle
Geheimdienstler oder Leute aus dem
Verteidigungsministerium es gibt da
keine Wirtschaftswissenschaftler es gibt
keine Juristen es gibt keine Politiker
da sind nur
Geheimdienstvertreter und und viele
davon haben tatsächlich da gearbeitet
und dem Geheimdiensten inklusive Putin
was bedeutet das nun das bedeutet dass
sie dieselbe Sprache sprechen sie
benutzen dieselben Begriffe und diese
Begriffe kommen aus den 80er Jahren aus
dem kgb-zeiten all diese Leute haben
dasselbe psychologische Trauma
sie mögen den Westen nicht sie schöpfen
Verdacht gegen Westen denn
wegen des zusammenfalls der Zerfalls der
Sowjetunion haben sie an ihrem sozialen
Status verloren das ist eine ein
riesiges Trauma für Sie sie verstehen
nicht warum dieser
plötzlich passierte deswegen haben sie
paranoa sie haben Angst vor der neuen
Revolution vor der neuen Katastrophe sie
denken diese neue Katastrophe kann
jederzeit passieren deswegen haben sie
so paranoa in Bezug auf die Proteste
innerhalb des Landes und Hannover in
Bezug auf den Westen
ihrer Meinung nachdenkt denke der Westen
nur daran Russland zu zerstören sie
glauben fest daran
wir denken dass sei Propaganda aber
dieser Leute selbst sind davon überzeugt
aufrichtig überzeugt sie sind davon
überzeugt dass der Westen plant wie
Russland zerstört werden kann und
deswegen lohnt er sich ein
Präventivschlag zu geben in diesem Fall
Überfall auf Ukraine
das heißt der der Wunsch vieler oder die
Mutmaßung vieler wenn Putin weg ist dann
gibt es auch keine Probleme mehr ist
quasi falsch wenn ich in die Chats hier
gucke dann sehe ich auch viele
Kommentare die in diese Richtung gehen
hier schreibt zum Beispiel Angela heller
über Facebook glauben wir wirklich nach
putin wird es besser es kann schlimmer
kommen das ist die Meinung dieser Userin
und Alex kommen 31 schreibt über Youtube
sagen wir es doch einfach im Moment gibt
es in Russland niemanden der Putin reell
beerben könnte und gleichzeitig dem
Westen gegenüber gemäßigter wäre kann
man das so sagen wenn Putin Weg ist
heißt es nicht dass es danach
automatisch besser wird sondern
möglicherweise aus Sicht des Westens
schlimmer
in der Tat
kann man das sagen es gibt Gründe das zu
sagen sehr viele Menschen in Russland
haben dieses Traummann des Zerfalls der
Sowjetunion erlebt sie waren Zeitzeugen
russland hat an seinem Status verloren
keine Großmacht mehr das wird sehr
emotional von manchen Menschen empfunden
auch in den Geheimdiensten und den
Verteidigungsministerium ob es eine
Chance gibt dass ein demokratischer
Anführer kommt ich glaube diese Schanzen
sind gering warum es gibt keine
demokratischen Strukturen in Russland es
gibt schlicht keine demokratischen
Institutionen keine demokratischen
Parteien keine Gesellschaft praktisch
keine Zivilgesellschaften mehr die
irgendwie die öffentliche Meinung
beeinflussen könnten unsere
oppositionsanführer sitzen im Gefängnis
Alexa
sie sitzen alle
Gefängnis bzw in den Strafkolonien
diejenigen die immer gesehen sind sie
sind nicht in Russland natürlich
versuchen Sie etwas zu tun dass es die
einzige Hoffnung die bleibt allerdings
heutzutage innerhalb Russlands
politische aktiv zu werden gegen die
Politik von Kreml ist unmöglich
deswegen
verstehe ich dieses Skepsis
trotzdem habe ich die Hoffnung dass das
noch keiner Katastrophe ist
es soll noch Hoffnung geben
[Musik]
Hoffnung auf die Veränderungen zum
besseren als
der destroika kam und Anfang der 90er
war ich noch selbst sehr jung niemand
hat das erwartet meine Eltern haben das
nicht erwartet aber das ist trotzdem
passiert genauso hoffe ich dass diese
Chance noch besteht auch jetzt
beim Blick in den Chat sehe ich dass
Serdar sich für die Weitergabe der Frage
bedankt das haben wir natürlich sehr
gerne gemacht und freuen uns natürlich
über sehr viele weitere Fragen und
Kommentare die ich natürlich versuche
gerne auch anhören soldatov
weiterzugeben also bitte rege
kommentieren und Fragen stellen wir
freuen uns hier im Team über ihre
Beteiligung Herr Salat auf sie haben die
Regimekritiker gerade angesprochen die
Opposition dann lassen Sie uns darauf
einen Blick werfen welche Möglichkeiten
es überhaupt gibt Widerstand zu leisten
und welche Form von Sabotage z.B auch
sichtbarer Widerstand ist Moritz neues
fast das zusammen
seit Kriegsbeginn immer wieder Meldungen
über mysteriöse Brände wie hier in einem
Chemiewerk nahe Moskau die Hintergründe
oft unklar und dort begann die
Brandserie mit der April brennt ein
Forschungsinstitut der
luft-180 km von Moskau entfernt manche
der Feuer sind in Grenznähe und damit in
Reichweite ukrainischer Waffen
theoretisch wäre es möglich dass es sich
um ukrainische Angriffe handelt doch
andere sind viel zu weit weg meinen auch
Beobachter
wir wissen nicht wer dafür
verantwortlich ist aber mit Unfällen hat
das nichts zu tun das ist klar zu
erkennen dahinter steckt schon eine Art
System alle paar Wochen passiert etwas
und zwar in verschiedenen Regionen
Birds und dann in Gleisen seit
Kriegsbeginn auffällig viele Züge in
Russland die russischen Behörden
sprechen lange von technischen Fehlern
doch im Netz und auf telegram wird immer
wieder zur Manipulation von Bahngleisen
aufgerufen stoppt die Waggons lautet der
Name des Kanals das Ziel Panzer und
andere Equipment das in die Ukraine
transportiert wird aufzuhalten
militanter Protest in einem Land in dem
Widerstand hart bestraft wird
es beginnt sich etwas zu entwickeln mehr
Menschen fangen an nachzudenken nicht
dass sie alle rausgehen würden und
schienen zersägen um Züge aufzuhalten
aber viele bereiten sich auf solche
Dinge vor und von manchen Gruppen werden
diese Vorbereitungen gesteuert
wohin das alles führt das weiß natürlich
keiner
fest steht bereits kleine Aktionen
können etwas bewirken und russische
Truppen vor Probleme stellen
Herr soldatov sehen Sie auch dass sich
da mehr Widerstand entwickelt oder wie
ein User namens Daniel terula über
Youtube fragt ist bei diesen hohen
Verlusten nicht vermehrt mit Widerstand
im Inneren von Russland zu rechnen
normalerweise ja gab es tatsächlich
solche Angriffe und normalerweise sind
sie mit der Mobilmachung verbunden denn
in diesem Zeitpunkt auch diejenigen die
nicht an den Krieg denken wollen
verstehen plötzlich dass da sie
unmittelbar davon betroffen wird sie
oder ihre Familie und dann gibt es
Brände in ein berufungsämtern dass ihm
geernter wo hin die Reservisten kommen
sollen was erscheinen sollen und da gibt
es Akten über die Reservisten
es ist nun nicht klar wann die zweite
Welle der Mobilmachung beginnt deswegen
kann man jetzt nicht prognosieren wie
diese Proteste sich entwickeln aber ich
habe keine Zweifel daran dass mit der
zweiten Welle der mobil machen und diese
Anschläge wieder an Bedeutung gewinnen
natürlich gibt es auch Sabotage seitens
ukrainischer Geheimdiensten denken Sie
an den Anschlag auf die krimbrücke es
gibt auch andere ukrainische Operationen
in Russland für sie ist es sehr wichtig
diese Logistik und diese Infrastruktur
kaputt zu machen die Infrastruktur die
russische Streitkräfte an die Frontlinie
transportiert
Herr soldato hier im Chat sind viele
Fragen zum Gesundheitszustand von
Vladimir Putin zum Beispiel fragt PK
über Youtube was kann man über Putins
Gesundheitszustand bzw seine
voraussichtliche Lebens Erwartung sagen
da können wir natürlich nicht in die
Glaskugel blicken aber viele haben das
ja auch noch mal zum Anlass genommen zu
spekulieren weil er jetzt diese
Jahrespressekonferenz abgesagt hat die
ja normalerweise traditionell immer zum
Jahresende gibt mehrere Stunden lang
dieses Jahr offenbar nicht was ist für
sie eine mögliche Erklärung
natürlich es ist schwer in deiner
Meinung darüber zu haben ich bin nicht
sein Arzt ich bin nicht in seiner Macht
sie erkennen
allerdings habe ich einige Informationen
von meinen Kontakten und ich kann
berichten dass er keine großen
Gesundheitsprobleme hat er hat
tatsächlich diese Jahrespressekonferenz
abgesagt aber das war ein politischer
Schritt und das sehen wir jetzt
wollte auch keine Rede an die Nation
halten also keine Rede im russischen
Parlament
stattdessen besuchte er das Kollegium
des
Verteidigungsministeriums und hielt da
eine Rede in dieser Rede hatte eine sehr
wichtige Erklärung gemacht
da wurde es klar er rechnet mit einem
langen Krieg und deswegen verspricht er
den Militärs Unterstützung und nur
Waffen auf dieser Sitzung hat er diese
wichtige Erklärung gemacht er hat gesagt
die russische Armee wird wachsen
[Musik]
das heißt Latina Puten bereitet sich auf
einen langen Krieg vor
dieser Krieg wird noch mehr
Opfer fördern es werden noch mehr
russische Soldaten an diesem Krieg
teilnehmen deswegen besuchte er das
Verteidigungsministerium genau diese
Menschen sind jetzt für ihn wichtig
nicht Journalisten nicht die
Abgeordneten nur mit den Militärs Villa
reden das ist ein Plan für die nächsten
Jahre
daran anschließend eine letzte Frage die
ich gerne für heute an Sie weitergeben
möchte Gremlin fragte über Youtube wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass sich die
russischen Soldaten umdrehen und in
Richtung Moskau marschieren
solche Diskussionen solche Gespräche und
Hoffnungen gab es seit dem Beginn der
Mobilmachung Ende September leider gibt
es jedoch keine Anzeichen dafür dass
russische Soldaten in der Lage sind das
zu machen
das System von repressalen funktioniert
auch innerhalb der Armee
der
Inlandsgeheimdienst FSB
führt auch Repressalien gegen die
Militärs durch es gibt eine spezielle
Abteilung für die
militärabwehr in jeder Militär Division
Bataillon und so weiter und diese
Menschen beobachten wie die
Soldaten so ticken und natürlich kann
man nicht erwarten das russische
Soldaten
Richtung Krämer gehen
sich in die ukrainische Gefangenschaft
begeben wir werden sehen natürlich
können das große Katastrophen an der
Front geben das könnte die Lage ändern
aber nun glaube ich sehen wir eine
ziemlich stabile Situation es gibt nicht
so viele Verluste das heißt dass die
politische Kontrolle auf der Seite des
Krämers ist
das ist die Einschätzung des russischen
geheimdienst-experten andre soldato
vielen Dank für ihre Einschätzungen für
die Beantwortung der Fragen und vielen
Dank liebe Userinnen und User dass sie
aktiv mitgemacht haben bis zum nächsten
Mal einen schönen Abend vom ganzen Team
hier machen sie es gut tschüss